nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir philippe leroy bonsoir
mon fait alors finir cette semaine sort
cloclo l'excellent film de florent
emilio siri et nous avons décidé de nous
intéresser nous aussi à claude françois
mais à travers un sosie de la star vous
êtes fan de cloclo depuis 12 ans ensuite
graines de stars éphémères à 20 ans et
puis vous êtes battus ensuite pour
devenir claude françois vous dites
aujourd'hui je vis ma passion et c'est
tout ce qui compte c'est vrai bah vous
nous raconterez notre histoire à 20
heures
[Musique]
philippe rebond soit vous êtes né le 8
septembre 1952 à fismes petit village de
250 habitants dans l'âme armes vous êtes
l'avant dernier d'une famille de cinq
enfants mais surtout le seul garçon
c'est vrai il était petit vous aviez
déjà vos claudette alors eh oui oui le
virus de la variété française c'est
votre père qui vous le transmet il est
commercial pendant la semaine et il est
batteur dans un petit orchestre le
week-end c'est ça alors en plus y'a
salut les copains que vous écoutez tous
les jours à 17h sera numéro 1 oui on
vous écoute et qui clôt sardou
gérard lenorman une la musique anglo
saxonne ne vous attire pas beaucoup pas
spécialement non est déjà clos et oui on
veut commencer à chanter le jeudi soir
juste après les répétitions de votre
père qui vous reproche en fait de ne pas
savoir chanter on mesure et oui c'était
un gros calvaire pour moi et il m'a
jamais vraiment trop opaque encourager
je les empêche pas de chanter dans votre
salle de bain avec non un peigne pour
faire le micro elle approche et tout va
lui n'ont même pas de porte
pourquoi il croyait pas en vous parce
qu'à cette époque là j'étais un peu
jeune et il trouvait que rentrer dans le
domaine de la musique c'était pas
c'était parce que je devais faire quoi
j'aurais préféré peut-être avoir un
enfant un fils
intellectuel mais c'est un peu comme le
vrai tokelau un oui les mêmes problèmes
avec son père pareil ouais ouais alors
tout ça vous éloigne de l'école de pas
un très bon élève sinon pas ne prendrai
même pas la peine de passer votre bac
non non non j'avais trop envie de
travailler à 17 ans donc dans un bal
populaire vous rencontrez ce qu'ils vont
devenir vos premiers musiciens et là
comme votre père vous commencez à faire
la tournée des bals défaite le week-end
et le restant de la semaine vous avez un
emploi administratif dans une entreprise
de travaux publics oui cet âge là c'est
beaucoup de manque de sommeil parce que
bon c'était samedi soir dimanche après
midi dimanche soir quelquefois le lundi
soir et le lundi matin fallait
travailler et le mardi matin en fait
envoyé ouais voilà vous aviez toujours
un pot de miel avec vous pour votre voix
oui mais non mais au bout de quelques
mois vous commencez à vous faire un nom
dans la région et vous découvrez en fait
le plaisir d'être une star quoi c'est à
dire que quand vous êtes en train de
ranger le matériel il ya cinq-six fille
qui nous attendent oui s'il vous plaît
oui ah oui j'adore
puis je pouvais choisir j'en ai profité
alors en 1973 après trois ans de
carrière vous êtes devenu la vedette des
fêtes de village et dans votre
répertoire ce que les fans apprécient
surtout ce sont les morceaux de claude
françois oui il ya une certaine lesdites
qui vous dit tu sais quand tu chantes
comme d'habitude j'ai l'impression que
c'est claude et c'est un petit peu aussi
que qui m'ont encouragé à me disait tu
devrais avoir un répertoire et salle
cocteau un jour en lisant le magazine
podium à le magazine de claude françois
votre soeur la plus petite tombe sur une
annonce polydor recherche de jeunes
talents oui j'ai donc passé une audition
à la maison de disques et un directoire
6 et intéresser un mois quand 10 on
écoute philippe je vais te trouver du
matériel en l'occurrence des chansons et
on va travailler enfin mais je vais lui
signe un contrat de septembre quand même
paul ou alors c'est pas mal heureux nous
la play 3 ans
polydor vous branche avec michael ellam
à épaule sébastien qui sont des grands
auteurs de l'époque et qui vous écrivent
des chansons c'est la première
conséquence la deuxième c'est que et une
secrétaire chez polydor kane copine et
voilà et ça sera la mère de vos deux
premiers enfants voilà ça a duré
quelques années quand même 18 ans alors
à l'époque vous ressemblez pas encore
vraiment à cloclo 1 plutôt mike brant
les cheveux longs bouclés faisait des
pattes d'eph vous avez des boots avec
des talons de 8 cm chemise comme ça j'ai
eu chaud
mais votre voix est de plus en plus
proche de celle de claude françois on
vous en fait le reproche d'ailleurs
beaucoup même dans la mesure où quand
mes disques arrivé en radio au musée
dont ces troc locaux ouais mais vous ne
pouvez rien et non parce que j'ai
tellement travaillé ses chansons avec
mon orchestre pendant des années que
finalement c'est vrai que quelque part
au bout d'un certain temps la voix
s'imprègne un peu les hangars des
intonations et voilà que de voir un peu
bas comme d'habitude par exemple je me
lève et je te bouscule tu ne te réveille
pas comme d'habitude
alors rencontré que le clos dans une
émission de daniel gilbert qui s'appelle
12h30 alors ils passent une heure et
demie à faire maquiller quand à wii
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient à coeur je sais
pas paraîtrait qu'ils mettaient des cils
supplémentaires
mais tu es quand même temps vous
maquillez vous
quart d'heure vingt minutes
avec le rasage compris leur après le
maquillage ce jour-là vous croisez
cloclo dans le couloir donc oui un
événement m'attaque de soleil pour une
bonne chose c'est comme un rêve oui oui
un moment je vous dirai pas alors suite
à cette émission vous participer à un
concours très important à l'époque qui
s'appelle la rose d'or d'antibes oui
voilà qu'un jury de professionnels il ya
souchon wii qui chantera mots en 1830
mais il finissait troisième quand même
oui prix d'interprétation
parcours que j'ai fait le pas le même
que celui d'alain souchon
la nuit suivante vous dormez au martinez
à cannes dans une chambre à côté de
nicoletta ah oui pour m'étais nos
chaussures est la porte d'entrée de la
chambre et le hamas tayssir et
je débarquais dans un monde moi qui
sortais de ma compagne 250 habitants et
ouais mais bon vous parvenez pas à
décoller quand même oui parce qu'en fait
le quatrième 45 jours que j'ai pu faire
bon j'en ai malgré tout vendu 10 me à
l'époque c'était trop mal s'amortit
c'est la production est alors un jour le
directeur artistique de polydor vous dit
vous chantez trop comme cloclo quoi ça
va plus ouais je parle de la maison de
disques en allant frapper malgré tout
vos portes de des éditions bod la
musique qui m'avait proposé
une superbe chanson activement michael
elana vaud propose une chanson qui
s'appelle petite fille mais que vous
refusez et qui deviendra un énorme tube
we 2 jean luc lahaye ce le titre femme
que j'aime voilà je suis passé à côté
d'un truc à dire oui mais oui salue tous
les fans
et oui et pourquoi ouais en fait j'ai
pas refuser la chanson c'est que je
pouvais pas me libérer de mon contrat en
fait c'est ça et puis bon trois mois
après je n'ai qu'à les sors tes fans de
gènes hla ça marche plus du tout pour
payer votre loyer faire vivre votre
famille lui travaillé au crédit lyonnais
oui et puis pour une boîte de produits
capillaires il se fournissait la poutre
décolorante le code utilisé chez carita
et voilà et un jour vous allez chez
carita et vous voyez claude quoi qui
sort oui oui je savais
il nécessaire couper les cheveux se
faire faire des balayages si vous
apprenez ce jour là c'est que claude
françois quand il faisait couper les
cheveux il ramassait tous les cheveux
par terre parce qu'il avait peur qu'on
lui fasse un truc vous dis oui
exactement c'est vrai oui oui c'est vrai
ils repartent et chaque fois que son
enveloppe
et puis le 11 mars 1978 cloclo meurt au
sommet de sa gloire à 39 ans vous
souvenez vous vous êtes à ce moment là
oui j'étais dans leur inverse non à 5
heures de l'après midi j'étais demandeur
transat en train de me faire bronzer jeu
j'y croyais pas à quoi je pensais que
c'était un canular et je me suis pas
possible c'est n'importe quoi après bon
s'est mis en face tout alors là vous
abandonnez votre carrière d'artiste vous
perdez votre boulot d'abord parce qu'on
vous envoie en région paca on voulait se
introduire les produits capillaires un
peu chez tous les coiffeurs une fois que
c'est fait on vous vire oui exactement
passé la zone ah oui ah oui là c'est
grand trou noir votre femme vous quitte
en plus oui en même temps votre fils
tourne mal oui ils se droguent ouais ça
c'est dur c'est très dur j'ai eu avec
moi pendant cinq ans j'ai eu un mal fou
à m'en sortir et
voulu faire la morale
je vais te cacher jury fut prôné son
shit allait le mettre dans le temps dans
les wc dit tiens regarde inde mais voilà
rien à faire voilà non non non et votre
fille vous tourne le dos pourquoi
je me pose encore des questions
aujourd'hui mais je pense que ça m'a
manqué pour beaucoup
vous les voyez aujourd'hui non non vous
y pensez tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours alors là pour éviter de
devenir clochard vous donnez coiffeur à
domicile
oui oui
et oui j'ai fait tous les métiers
et puis un jour buvez un verre dans une
discothèque tenu par un copain vous
chantez comme d'habitude et tout le
monde trouve ça génial oui un oui c'est
vrai il patrons de discothèques vous dis
pas être cool si tu reviens avec quatre
danseuses moi je te laisse chanter mais
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai travaillé
j'ai j'ai monté un show et à chaque fois
que je passais menu du repas ce mois
prochain et puis de fil en aiguille j'ai
mon âge attaqué mon planning kiziki qui
prenait de l'ampleur et
à la bouffe est vachement attention aux
costumes ah bah oui vous achetez des
lentilles de couleur oui et puis petit à
petit vous prenez traits de votre idole
vous ai fait de la chirurgie non pas du
tout donc c'est uniquement du mimétisme
ah oui alors la consécration viendra en
2003 vous ferez 40 dates organisé par
nice matin devant 4000 personnes et 8000
personnes à toulon c'est quand même
vachement bien oui je pense pas que ce
grand soir était beaucoup plus bas oui
oui c'est vrai on se fout ça c'était un
grand moment c'est un moment magique
pour moi la boudronnée claude françois
pour de vrai abel la wii mais juste de
jus dans le camping car je me préparais
jeu rendant le personnage et après
j'oublie tout je suis plus cloclo non je
suis moi aujourd'hui ou fait 150 dates
par an oui pas mal
ça vous rappelle quelque euros par mois
vivre de sa passion c'est extraordinaire
oui c'est ça alors finalement vous avez
été claude françois plus longtemps que
lui même
ah bah oui jamais fait le rapprochement
entre eux est-ce que vous avez tenté de
vous recycler en sosie de jérémie rénier
bonnes questions non non mais j'avoue il
ya eu un gros travail de fait ses excès
et l'art sans vent salé flagrante c'est
marrant nous mêmes en fait attention
dans votre salle de bain oui changez pas
d'en couvrir du un faux pas perdre
l'autre sous la boue à la voix est
formidable problème à renonce pas mal
non moi je suis hyper content d'être
répété claude françois
merci de votre témoignage public
françois était en vie il sera exactement
comme vous voilà la fois et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater le il a l'habitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu